so we had some elections last night and
along with Republicans barely and only
possibly holding a very red seat last
night in Ohio the other big news that I
have is that for the first time voters
have successfully repealed one of those
horrible right-wing right-to-work laws
this time in the state of Missouri
what is right-to-work right-to-work laws
exist in 27 states would have been
twenty eight if it weren't for
yesterday's vote in Missouri and what
right-to-work laws do is they prevent
unions security agreements between
unions and companies by guaranteeing
workers can't be forced as a condition
of taking a particular job to join and
have to pay dues to a union or not join
a union right they can't be forced
either way but this is kind of a red
herring because federal law already
makes it illegal to force people to join
unions and without getting into the
minutia and the specifics of exactly how
these laws work the long and short of it
is that right-to-work laws are great for
corporate power they take away power and
the ability to negotiate collectively
for workers for their benefit and
Republicans passed such a law in
Missouri and yesterday voters voted to
block the law this was called
proposition a in yesterday's election in
Missouri it would have made it illegal
for unions to charge fees for workers
they represent who don't want to pay
them and it was defeated by a roughly
two-to-one margin in Missouri this is a
massive massive victory at no time in
American history has a right-to-work law
been overturned by popular referendum we
can talk about it economically we can
talk about it politically economically
this is good economists have studied
right-to-work laws for a while and what
they found is they don't help the
economy there's a study from Hofstra
which shows that right-to-work becomes
sort of a wash for the economy in total
but it shifts some money away from
workers and towards business owners or I
guess we would say it shifts it up the
opposite of trickle down its trickle up
I guess we would call it the Economic
Policy Institute says
that right to work has lowered wages by
about 3% for both Union and non-union
workers and economically it's not a good
thing the political perspective is sort
of like Ohio's 12th district results
right this is a signal about how the
November midterms might go because when
you look at the county level results for
the repeal of this right-to-work law in
Missouri counties in Missouri even
counties that voted for Trump in big
numbers like 60 to 40 Trump Hillary 70
to 30 Trump Hillary they voted to repeal
right-to-work and that is really
important because there are people who
claim that a platform of economic
justice and real progressive populism
wouldn't work in red states sure that
might work in the district were
Alexandria Acacio Cortez is running but
that's not going to work in red
districts they framed correctly economic
populism and economic justice can work
in those red districts the problem is
that it's becoming toxically partisan
and people don't realize that they're
voting against their own best interest
in Missouri good results here yeah and I
think they did frame the issue correctly
with the no on Prop a campaign here in
Missouri you just got to show that in
the right-to-work states that means less
money for the workers more money for the
CEOs and that just feels unjust to
people you can easily make that case
that it's not fair
now the next step the next awakening
that would be great for Missouri
Republicans to have is okay let's see we
didn't want the right-to-work law and
Republicans did that means that when I
vote in November I should not vote for
those same Republicans because those are
the people that are going to try and try
again because remember they only have to
get it through once for it to become the
law we have to vote it down every single
time to prevent it from becoming the law
and Republicans know this so the next
layer in fighting the cognitive
dissonance and realizing that what you
do in November also relates to
right-to-work is to remember if I don't
want right-to-work I shouldn't after
having voted down right-to-work in
August go in November and vote for the
exact same people that are going to try
it again
I don't know if that's going to happen
because we still see that the partisan
nature of those midterms gets a lot of
people voting down party lines what we
do realize is that the Republican voters
don't actually agree with the policy of
the Republican candidates that by and
large they're going to vote for in
November and those Republican voters in
the middle of the country are by and
large against Trump's tariffs right yes
combine that with this new democratic
message of economic justice I think you
can turn a lot of them over there's two
explanations one is ignorance they don't
understand that if they're against the
tariffs and against right-to-work that
you shouldn't vote for Republicans
there's another interpretation which is
less negative I guess we would say which
is they get it but there are some
overarching issues that for them are
just more important like for example for
religious voters what about abortion and
it might just be that determines who
they vote for more than the economic
policy I think in different states in
different counties in different
districts it's probably two different
proportions one or the other there are
some interesting races that we're going
to be covering in these midterms we're
going to be doing more candidate
interviews I will be running for you
soon my interview with JD Schulten who's
running in Iowa against extremists
depraved disgusting doofus Steve King
and also my interview from Netroots
nation with current congressman Tim Ryan
who's a Democrat in Ohio very
enlightened guy he knows about
mindfulness meditation he understands
Medicare for all and modern monetary
theory so I interviewed him in New
Orleans over the weekend and we're gonna
be running my interview with him soon I
may have to move to Ohio just so I had
the opportunity to vote for him well
where he represents it's pretty
economically ravaged so I'm not saying
it's a bad place we actually have a lot
of viewers in that district and an
affiliate station but I don't know for
sure that it's the place that 1/2 Ford
wants to live in right it's not a bad
place every place is great and
everything's wonderful and all that
stuff but I think that you know you're
probably doing ok in Boston ok send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show and we do have hatred mail
coming up after the break I'm pleased to
tell you that today's show is
underwritten by better help.com slash
Pakman therapy is important we have a
real crisis in our country not just
people who could benefit from mental
health services but the stigma that
surrounds mental health services and as
many people in the audience know lots of
people in my family work in the field of
mental health and I have made it a
mission of the show to at any
opportunity make clear that there is
absolutely no shame whatsoever in going
to talk to someone when you feel that
that's the right thing to do and that's
what better help provides you get a
fully licensed and experienced
psychologists and therapists through
video phone and text it's less expensive
than meeting in person with a counselor
after three months the price goes down
even more but you get the same
professional service that you would from
going into somebody's office and you
also get unlimited access you can speak
to a counselor every day if you want
signing up is easy you go to better help
calm slash Pakman fill out a
questionnaire they will pair you with a
therapist that works for you but you're
always able to switch to somebody else
if there's a better fit available go to
better help calm slash Pakman it's so
easy to sign up and get started we're
putting a link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube it is
better help calm a /pa que ma n